a place that can help with all of those
resolutions is
the gym yeah rocky is live at the newest
location of redemption fitness
where you can cycle do boot camps box
vegas style hey rocky
hey you guys yeah you said vegas style
and i mean
a show girl on on a spin bike you've got
frank sinatra with boxing gloves you
can't get any more
vegas than that brian you're the ceo of
redemption fitness
why is this so vegas centric yeah so we
basically took all the elements of vegas
and kind of put on one roof
we made a fitness nightclub so we
invested over
250 000 in audio and lighting it goes to
be the music it's something that guy
never seen before in fitness
wow okay well speaking of fitness
nightclub let's walk into one of the
fitness nightclub rooms here
so tell us where we're going and what
you guys offer yeah so this is
our rep and rebel room so we offered
various boot camp classes in here and
also one of our bread and butter classes
rebel
so we actually have water bags over here
offering different boxing classes
the instructors up there on the stage
kind of like the dj hype woman
they're manning the lights the audio and
everything's kind of to the be the music
so what kind of classes do you guys
actually offer at redemption because i
know there's there's a couple
different types specifically right yeah
yeah yeah so we have four modalities uh
three different rooms we offer boxing
boot camp
cycling and a heated fitness class so we
also have a heated pilates
boot camp with kettlebells and also bar
and this is your new location your other
location
your first one is in summerlin this is
your henderson location exactly and
there's a couple of different things you
can enjoy here right other than your
summerlin yep absolutely so we at the
heat of fitness element our grand
opening was yesterday as all week long
we're actually offering free classes all
week so check us out
redemptionfitness.com did you did you
guys hear that
free classes free classes all week so
come take as many classes as you want
check out redemptionfitness.com or
henderson location
redemptionfitness.com for free classes
there's no better way to start
2021 this has been a tough ride yeah
yeah it has been yeah so the word
redemption
it means a lot right now yeah yeah yeah
so our hashtag is redeem yourself right
no matter what you're going through a
lot of people think the physical element
with fitness
but a lot of it's mental right so it's
getting into that mental head space
whether you're going through a breakup
or anything in your life
fitness is really good for all of that
and that's kind of what we preach here
so come introduce us to your to your
beautiful instructors here oh sorry yeah
i want to i want to get into it
so just tell me what's the move that i
should do you can start by doing this at
home or at redemption fitness
to get into the spirit maria tell us
simple jab process okay okay one two two
fold your pen up jab
okay one two three we're job crossing
into twenty twenty one
all right four o'clock i'm gonna put on
some gloves myself okay
all right jack crossing the 20-41
looking good rocky i like that uppercut
you got a good uppercut
we'll check back in with rocky during
the four o'clock newscast